تمت تسمية
شلالات شوشون بشلالات نياجرا في الغرب ،
حيث يرى معظم الناس الشلالات من
سطح المراقبة
ولكن الطريقة الفريدة جدًا لمشاهدة الشلالات
هي التجديف بالكاياك إلى قاعدتها
التجديف بالكاياك في وادي نهر الثعبان هو
مغامرة جميلة للغاية  ستمر على
نفسها
بمحاذاة مجموعة من
الشلالات التي تتدحرج
مئات الأقدام لأسفل على طول حافة الوادي
على طول الطريق التي ستمر بها تحت
الجسر الرئيسي
وستتمكن من رؤية قافز القاعدة من
جميع أنحاء العالم الذين
ينزلون بالمظلات إلى  الجانب الجنوبي
من الوادي ، هذا هو المكان الوحيد في
البلد حيث يمكنك القيام بذلك بشكل قانوني
في منتصف الطريق حيث نواجه
شلالات الأعمدة وفي عيني ، يسقط العمود هو
مطالبتنا الخفية الحقيقية بالشهرة هنا في
الوادي بالطريقة التي يكون بها النهر
قطع الصخور
على مر القرون
وتغيير
القنوات باستمرار لإنشاء أحواض سباحة جديدة ، فمن المدهش حقًا
أننا عادة ما نأتي إلى هنا لمجرد الحصول على
ارتفاع صغير لطيف في الحصول على تمرين جيد
ولكن هذا "  إنه جميل كما
ترون ، يمكنك التنزه عليه ، حيث يكون الماء
منعشًا إذا كنت ترغب في الغطس قليلاً
عندما تقترب من الزاوية
وتظهر الشلالات لأول مرة ،
إنه أمر مذهل تمامًا الآن هذه هي
الطريقة التي ترى بها شوشون يسقط
تشعر أنه في صدرك ، فإن السقوط
هائل ، يمكنك أن تشعر بالرذاذ ،
إنها تجربة جميلة وفريدة من نوعها